Every Facebook feed has that couple:...
...the ones always posting mushy gushy status updates...
...and googly-eyed pictures from romantic vacations.
It turns out there could be a scientific reason for all that oversharing.
It's called relationship-contingent self-esteem,...
...an unhealthy kind of self-esteem that comes from romantic relationships.
It's been linked for a long time to lower overall self-esteem...
...and higher social anxiety.
But new research shows that people with RCSE...
...are also more likely to use social media...
...to publicize how amazing their relationships are.
It's also more common among introverts,...
...who may be less apt to share the details of their happiness with pals offline.
While RCSE is considered a negative thing,...
...these posts don't necessarily mean the couple is overcompensating.
In fact, according to researchers, many of these couples really may be just that happy.
And listen, you can always unfollow.